I think we are living in such an amazing
time right now I mean if you are not
being challenged in some way in your
life you're not alive and all of this is
an initiation and I don't believe that
you have to go to any school of ancient
wisdom perched in the Himalayas or for
information or training any longer if
you see your life as the school as the
initiation then you can no longer be a
victim to your life you're going to have
to meet the challenges in your life from
a greater level of Mind greater than the
mind that created and so there have been
plenty of peer-reviewed articles on the
power of Peace Gathering projects lower
crime that lower trauma incidences of
death and economic growth it's all
related to what's happening right now
for us and it's not enough though for us
to just focus on peace and expect the
World to Change because in the peace
Gathering projects when the event was
over a lot of the crime and violence
returned back to its ceiling level again
it's more important for us not only to
embody that peace and feel it but then
to demonstrate it and when we begin to
demonstrate it I think we give people
permission to do the same that means
that we can't be preaching peace and
then be stuck in traffic and you know
flipping people off or you don't get to
stand up for peace if you have conflict
in your life so when we start I believe
start that self-contemplative process of
looking within and instead of judging
someone or something look to see if
there's an aspect of ourselves within
that person or when that situation that
we may need to change and if we're all
doing that at the same time something
greater greater Consciousness is going
to emerge and so I believe that it
should never be about a person
it should be about principles and when
we stand up for principles that creates
Community because you could be one
belief or another belief but if you're
sharing the same principles which are
joy and freedom and cooperation and
connection that's what builds
communities
so then
everything in our world right now is
reminding us of Separation whether it's
War whether it's violence whether it's
political deceit whether it's Prejudice
all of those things cause us to live by
those stress hormones and when we're
living in that state of survival we're
not trusting and we become more selfish
so then starting our day asking
ourselves what would be the greatest
expression of myself I'd like to present
to the world
and then making the choice to not get up
until we are that person I think that
begins to demonstrate greatness
and when there is adversity and when
there are challenges in our life the
question of course becomes how do we
become Supernatural
and that means we're going to have to do
what feels unnatural at first when
everybody else is in poverty and lack
that's the time to give
when everybody else is in fear and
vigilance that's the time to show
courage
when people are angry and hating and
Prejudiced that's the time to show
compassion people are competing to rush
to get to the top that's the time to
change your energy and draw the
experience to you
and if you keep doing what's unnatural
over and over again sooner or later
you're going to become Supernatural you
have to decide whether you are going to
live an intentional or accidental life
do you want to live an intentional or
accidental life most of the world lives
in accidental life most of the world
they wake up what do you do when you
first wake up check your phone right you
set some alarm because you have to drive
to some job that you hate
you check your phone and immediately
there's all the crisis out there all the
expectations on you all of the fears and
judgments all of the tasks that other
people have set for you you wake up like
an accident and start living according
to other people's demands for your time
you've already lost complete control of
your day
what if though you swapped it and said I
want to live a more intentional life
what does it even look like was an
intentional life look like well I think
it starts with a value
if you were to think about what is your
most important core value what would you
come up with right I've written two
books on it your one word built to serve
back there you can figure it out mine is
believe I want to spread more belief in
the world
what is your most important core value
that you want to organize your day
around
instead of responding to other people's
emergencies and losing complete control
of your day how about we organize with
intention for how we want to show up
today okay well that sounds great so how
do you do it well I'm going to give you
a couple tips that I use in my life that
I think can be valuable for you
number one your morning routine is so
critical you've heard it over and over
and over and over again from multiple
people Morning Routine Morning Routine
Morning Routine what's the difference
between a incredibly powerful morning
routine that allows you to be
Supernatural and do the things that are
beyond your comfort zone and and are not
by default in you yet
versus just a regular morning routine
the difference is the feeling this is
what most Achievers Miss okay most of
the world doesn't have a morning routine
with intent most of the world wakes up
falls into their day respond to the
people's emergencies hate their life
hate their day look back on the week
that just happened if you ever felt like
you've put so much work into this week
right you look at the end of the week I
worked so hard this week but I got
nothing done you ever feel that way why
because you're responding to other
people's emergencies instead of actually
doing a thing with intention that you
should be doing
okay so the purpose
for Achievers I have a morning routine
is to get the feeling the goal is not
just to wake up and do your workout or
do your meditation or do your prayer or
or whatever the thing is that's on your
list right we're great as Achievers at
checking off the boxes right check check
check check check I did it awesome pat
yourself on the back you feel good for
checking out the box but if you do not
feel
all powerful confident courageous belief
in yourself to start your day and have a
great day then your morning routine is
not working for you more important than
the task you get done is how you feel
about yourself and ready to start the
day
some people what they need to do is
actually tweak them on a routine and
some people what they need to do is this
is more likely the case you actually
have a good morning routine you're just
not doing it with the right focus and
intention because you say that you're
going to watch a video to get inspired
great perfect boy you're watching the
video You're brushing your teeth and
you're making your lunch and you're
preparing your coffee and you're doing a
million other things so you can check
the box to say yep watch the video but
you didn't get the feeling
and so it doesn't count
you need to feel old courageous powerful
belief in self ready to start the day
and have an amazing one or you have to
go back and fix your own routine or do
it again
starting your day to have intention to
do crazy new amazing big things
with a powerful morning routine okay
number two
look at your calendar
and think about how do you want to show
up today the most important part of my
morning routine I'll wake up I put on
some music usually the first thing I
play in the morning is Oldies play some
really I don't know the oldies just get
me going in the morning any song that
kind of gets you moving gets you flowing
gets you out of your state because we
all wake up kind of tired lines on your
face Etc right but then what song can
you put on because the fastest way to
change your state
and then I look at my calendar
I look at my calendar and ask myself how
do I want to show up for today
instead of having a a bucket list I
think your bucket list is your excuse
list things that one day you're gonna
get done forget that I'm getting stuff
done today you're getting stuff done
today your bucket list should be in your
calendar you're working towards actually
achieving things and so look at your
calendar for today look at your calendar
for the next week how do you want to
show up
so this morning I wake up I put on my
oldies and I'm looking at my calendar
and this is a Tuesday for today and I'm
filming YouTube videos on Tuesday
Tuesday is a day that I film my content
so how do I want to show up I want to
show up
present I want to show up and make some
of the best videos I've ever made I may
not achieve that objective but it's my
it's my goal it's my intention to show
up it's less important like did you get
the result today and more like are you
proud of the effort that you showed up
today I don't want to focus on team I
don't want to focus on emergencies in my
email I don't want to focus on social
media I don't want to delay and
procrastinate I want to get content out
for you guys believe Nation let's go I
want to show up even though I'm just
standing on my trampoline alone by
myself in my office I want this message
to reach millions of people
that's that's the intention that's when
I wake up I got my oldies playing and
then I'm looking at my calendar and say
this is how I want to show up most days
I don't remember what day it is when I
wake up I I had no idea that today was a
Tuesday when I woke up
I put on my oldies I look at the
intention
ready to go that does not have to take a
long time this doesn't have to be a two
hour morning routine
you're you could be great at it
you're just not going through the actual
exercise to ask yourself how do I want
to show up today
so look at your calendars it's a good
exercise think of what's coming up in
your calendar today what's coming up for
the rest of the day before you go to
sleep how do you want to show up
how do you want to show up in your
business or at your work how do you want
to show up for the people that you work
with how do you want to show up for your
family how do you want to show up
because when you set that morning
routine right step one create a powerful
morning routine that makes you feel bold
confident powerful a live belief in self
and two as a part of that having the
intention for how you want to show up
imagine if every day for the next year
you did just those two things
powerful morning routine that makes you
feel bold powerful courageous right and
two you set an intention every morning
of how you want to live today
whether you achieve it perfectly or not
but you did that every morning imagine
how much different your life is one year
from today
just by doing those two things
it's transformative
and then step number three is
in between
the activities during the day
remember your intention I have a
background on my cell phone it says
remember your intention so anytime I
look at my cell phone it's remember my
intention remember your intention
remember your what was my intention this
morning belief I got it I want to spend
more but I want to make amazing YouTube
content amazing videos for you guys
believe Nation remember the intention
because no matter what happened in the
morning you might forget it come noon
come two o'clock come four o'clock come
six o'clock you need the reminder
of your intention so have it on my cell
phone background the other thing that I
do is I will book things in 25 or 55
minute increments
so if I'm filming blocks of content if
I'm doing meetings with people if I'm
doing uh training events or seminars
there's always a five minute break
from when I stop one activity to when I
start the next activity
and one reason for that is just to make
sure that there's any technical issues
or one thing runs late or Etc I have a
little bit of a buffer but the more
important issue is that it allows me
that little window to reset the
intention for the next thing so
especially if you're switching tasks
you're coming home from work and you're
going you're going home and you're gonna
you're gonna see your spouse you're
gonna see your kids or you're switching
from one meeting to a next you're
switching from a meeting to making a
video or switching from video to write
your book you're switching between tasks
give yourself a little five minute
window to just remember the intention
again
it totally changes how you show up as a
human
if you are going from work to home even
if that's I'm I'm I my studio here is in
my home right even if I'm going from
here to outside the door
foreign
if I give myself a five minute break
in between activities from stopping
filming to then going to hanging out
with my wife
and I asked myself remember your
intention what was your intention for
today
okay belief how do I bring that to Nina
how do I bring that to my relationship
even though I've just made all these
videos and my head's going a mile a
minute and I'm so excited for all the
content that we're producing and making
and launching amazing
how do I now show up for my relationship
just that five minutes it doesn't even
have to take five minutes but just
asking the question
resets the priorities
takes you off of living on autopilot and
living in intention
it changes how I show up to when I'm
gonna go out and hang out with Nina
so do those things your life will
dramatically change powerful morning
routine
set your intention every morning
and then have little breaks to remind
yourself of what that intention was
throughout the day
whether it's your cell phone background
whether it's five minute breaks in
between switching tasks
if you can decide
that you want to stop living in
accidental life
stop living a reactionary life based off
of other people's priorities for your
time controlling your agenda
put up a little bit of defenses and
walls to say no this is my time this is
my life
I'm gonna start living it with intention
you do that
Everything Changes I promise you
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I have three kids and I've raised my
kids with these principals and and I
think uh there are critical periods Ed
where certain information uh is more
understood
in certain periods where uh you can you
can really Advance a teaching or an
understanding but children you know
their first six years of their life
they're very suggestible to information
and their brain waves are just in a
slower pattern so they don't have any
critical facilities or analytical
facilities so big boys don't cry little
girls should be seen and not heard money
is the root of all evil God is mad at
you you're gonna go to hell so kids just
take that all in without any filter and
that becomes the foundation of their
personality and our identity then you
throw in parents
there are 95 of the time running
unconscious programs while children have
mirror neurons and mirror neurons
emulate Behavior so when you're feeding
your kids when they were young you took
that spoon and you went like this
you didn't know you were doing that but
you were doing that and they were
watching you and you were watching them
and they were they were turning on the
same circuits in their brain that you
were turning on just so they could model
the behavior so so then you can't say
the kid stop being an emotional basket
case because you're not listening to
anything you're saying they're observing
Behavior so when a lioness takes her
Cubs out to hunt they sit and they watch
her and they're when they're watching
her she's priming their brain they're
actually going to emulate her behavior
so as they start observing her they
start turning on the same circuits they
will when they hunt so they start
imprinting it right
so then with children then
I call it the fast path to Enlightenment
because if you want to raise a great kid
you got to be the example and so
um you know there's certain principles
with children uh in certain critical
periods you don't tell your kids when
they're four years old you create your
reality fix this you know it's not
they're not ready for that but there are
certain things at certain periods of
time that are really healthy and and
teaching children how to shorten the
refractory period of their emotional
reactions is so important in simple
things like a trampoline
is a great way when a kid is upset
just change their stage let's go yeah
let's go okay and they jump and you jump
with them 10 minutes later
it's gone isn't that true and so then
you're teaching them that kind of
emotional intelligence
parents need to know that it's so
important to understand
to never rationalize with your kid when
they're emotional
why because do you want to hear anything
when you're emotional do you want to be
left alone because no new information
can enter their nervous system that is
not equal to the emotion that they're
experiencing it's not relevant
so then getting them past their
emotional state and teaching them how to
shorten their refractory period and then
timing
okay but they start getting ready for
bed and it's getting loving and it's
getting quiet and they're settling down
and get in bed with them and you lay
there and you say you know I had a tough
day today I've been working on my
frustration you know and I didn't do
very well today I just I got angry at a
few points I got frustrated and I stayed
that way for like three hours and you
just opened the door for kids and
they'll say yeah you know I was playing
today you know they'll automatically
said and I got so frustrated with my
friend Paris you know and I'll say well
that's all right you know that's normal
we all do that but what I care about the
most
is that if you had another opportunity
tomorrow in the same situation how would
you do it better oh my God and then
they'll say well I would do this and
then he said really if you do that this
is probably going to happen so let's
work on this together overcoming the old
self
allows us to become somebody else and
there is that period of transition yeah
I call it the void where there's just
not a lot happening
and you just got to be able to keep
going and continuously get to the end of
your belief where most people stop I
just had a fabulous conversation with
someone this weekend
broke through to the other side and now
there's so much magic happening around
this person but she's worthy now to
receive it and that's that that is the
key because the universe only gives us
what we think we're worthy of receiving
so we gotta come initiated into this and
understand it thousands of years of
programming that says that we have to
change things matter to matter you know
in three-dimensional reality and it will
take time but
to begin to connect to that resource
called the quantum field and create from
the field instead of from matter
there's a lot of unlearning that has to
go on I think this is a time in history
where it's not enough to know this is a
time in history to know how and if you
rewind the tape 10 years ago you know
information was the thing that
stimulated thought stimulated new ideas
and and as we learn new things we make
new Connections in our brains so as we
begin to add new Stitches into that
three-dimensional tapestry in our mind
we're beginning to cause our mind to
function in new ways but the key then is
to apply it to personalize it to do
something with it and in 10 years ago
when I went got in front of an audience
and talked about the application it
nobody wanted to step outside that
philosophical theoretical intellectual
realm right because doing something
means you're gonna have to change
something about yourself painful yeah
you're going to get uncomfortable right
and
um I think we're in an age of
information
and in an age of information ignorance
is a choice and because of Technology we
have access to so much content and
information creates awareness and
awareness is consciousness and you can't
have Consciousness without energy there
they work together so there's an
energetic change I think that's taking
place in the world right now where
people are so informed that old models
old paradigms are beginning to break
down whether it's the medical model or
the religious model the educational
model journalism uh the economy you know
politics it's all beginning to come to
the surface because something else has
to come out and and I think that one of
the things that people are realizing is
that you don't have to be a Buddhist
monk to do this or a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you just got to understand
the formula and just like any skill or
anything you learn
you got to go from thinking to doing to
being you got to take knowledge you
create the experience and if you keep
doing it over and over again you start
getting a skill or you start getting
wise about how to do it and you you know
that you know how to do it if we teach a
person then how to trade that
frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or I
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah we know that okay so let's
take your partner in business or take
your ex let's duct tape them put them in
a cannon and shoot them to the million
now what are you gonna do sooner or
later you got to reckon with yourself
and change right so then teach a person
then how to trade that emotion for an
elevated emotion now trade the emotion
for an elevated emotion right so you're
going to give that up and you're going
to practice feeling gratitude for as an
example yes the person says well I can't
feel gratitude and I say absolutely you
can because you don't practice feeling
it you practice spending most of your
time feeling hatred and frustration so
now it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or
you're part of yours to bloom once
they're able to feel even the small most
measure of gratitude where they start
feeling appreciation thankfulness
to its emotional signature when you when
you get something when you're receiving
something
when something has happened to you
or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened where it's
happening to you so the moment you open
your heart and you feel gratitude well
that emotion then is telling the body
that the experience has already occurred
and the thought then can make it into
the body because it's consistent with
the thought so now you're beginning to
program the autonomic nervous system
into a very specific Destiny you got to
maintain that modified State of Mind and
Body your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email that I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life unless of the
victim of your life we Define reality
with our senses and I think that is one
of the biggest Illusions so the
fundamental question is can you believe
in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind that your
brain has literally changed to look like
the event has already occurred now the
latest research in plasticity says
that's absolutely possible and can you
select a new possibility in the quantum
field and begin to emotionally Embrace
that future every single day to such a
degree that your body as the unconscious
mind the objective mind does not know
the difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to Signal new genes in new ways to
change your body to look like the
experience has already happened now yes
the latest research in epigenetics says
it's absolutely possible now think about
this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future that your body begins to
change to look like it's already
happened now this is where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it now it begins to come
to you you become the vortex for the
magnet to your destiny so then people
who come out of their meditation and
they say well I just focused on my
wealth why isn't it there well you're
not that good if you're asking why isn't
it there you're back to the old person
again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time
as an experiment as the scientist in
your life to keep your energy connected
to the to the dream of your future
and then see what kind of effects begin
to take place without moving into
impatience without moving into
frustration without starting to analyze
why it hasn't happened or when that is
the Trap of defining reality with your
senses so you have the thought of your
future and you don't see it then you
experience separation but people who are
practicing this work they have the
thought of their future and they feel
the emotion of their future they're
still connected to it right so that
takes practice and it's just learning
like hitting a golf ball hitting a
tennis ball dancing the salsa you know
crocheting whatever it is you gotta you
gotta start out staying real conscious
and learning then you get good at it and
gets to be instrumental gets to be fun
and that's that's what I want for
everybody that the Act of Creation
should be a blissful life ecstatic loose
free process and um and so
I love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
to prove to themselves that if they're
defined by the vision of the future then
they're not living by the memories of
the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people the unknown is a
scary place so they don't see that
future because they're used to seeing
that future with evidence with their
senses and you have to be able to get
beyond that and stay in the unknown stay
in that discomfort and then in that
moment to be begin to self-regulate like
oh I'm starting to feel a little anxiety
ooh I'm starting to feel a little
frustration that's the defining moment
where your body's going back to the past
because emotions are a record of the
past or you go into routine again so you
catch yourself
it's a victory and if you keep catching
yourself those victories add up and it's
not so much about your wealth or your
health or your freedom or your new
relationship
it's actually about who you become we
have research to show that 60 days of
meditation
five days a week will lengthen your life
the telomeres the little shoestrings on
the end of your DNA get longer that
means your biological age is changing so
we we have the evidence now
to show people what's possible we have
brain scans that that are so outside of
normal that when neuroscientists see
them they're blown away because the
amount of energy that's in the brain
during this transcendental moment is uh
hundreds of times outside of normal wow
I mean you can't make your brain do that
something is happening to you and that
person's having a transcendental moment
and we now know that we can predict it
and we now know that we can induce it I
think uh you know if we everything
starts with a thought I mean everything
that you do in your life you you have to
have a thought before you initiate an
action right so so if you believe that
your thoughts have something to do with
your destiny like any great leader in
history understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future or are
you going to live by the memories of the
past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning and
your brain is a record of the past it's
an artifact of everything you've learned
and experienced to this moment right
it's a it's a Memory Bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places and the
moment they start start turning on those
circuits those memories are actually
causing them to think in the past every
single one of those memories has an
emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences so then the moment they
recall the event or the they recall some
problem in their life they start feeling
unhappy they start feeling discouraged
they start feeling anxious now thoughts
of the language of the brain and
feelings of the language of the body and
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future and so
what happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this your body is your unconscious mind
it doesn't know the difference between
an experience in your life that creates
an emotion and an emotion that you can
create by thought alone so if you're
living by the same emotion every single
day and those emotions are influencing
your thoughts and you can't think
greater than how you feel or feelings
have become the means of thinking you're
thinking in the past your lens of the
future is going to be colored by the
past so you can't see possibilities so
most people like to wait for crisis or
disease or diagnosis before they wake up
yes enough to see well the challenge is
is that biology tends to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts be begin to fire
certain circuits in your brain the nerve
cells that fire together wire together
so all of a sudden you start getting
hardwired and those are the thoughts
that you can think the easiest at the
same time those thoughts produce
chemicals called emotions and the next
thing you know your body gets accustomed
to living by the same emotions and it
could be guilt it could be unhappiness
it could be pain but at least it's
familiar to you at least you can predict
it so some people would rather cling to
The Familiar than take a chance in
possibility so for most people then they
say well
I don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change is starting
to think about what you've been thinking
about and change it and and then when
you begin to observe those thoughts
you're no longer the program you're the
Consciousness observing just simply by
being an observer of your thoughts right
so so though so most people though when
they when you do that when you decide to
really take a look it's like letting a
match in a dark place so you feel
uncomfortable so it's easier to turn on
your TV it's easier to to play with your
cell phone to distract yourself from
those feelings well when you understand
that change really requires becoming
uncomfortable to a certain degree and
that's normal that you're leaving the
known and you're stepping into the
unknown then it begs the question what
thoughts do you want to fire and wire in
your brain because your attention on
those thoughts begins to reorganize
circuitry remold the brain when you're
feeling gratitude and your heart is over
open your broadcasting energy into the
field frequency a frequency you lay the
intent of the thought of your health or
your wealth that frequency can carry the
thought of your wealth it can carry the
thought of your health if you're
suffering you can't the suffering does
not carry that energy does not carry the
thought of your wealth it carries a
different set of thoughts so then so
then we're teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated right
and you better know how to self-regulate
and you have to know the moment you
disconnect from the energy of your
future because of some circumstance in
your life and you lose that feeling if
you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change the the
frustration from some experience in your
life back to the energy of your future
now
that requires Great awareness and great
effort but if you have a commune of
people that are practicing this on a
daily basis and they're connected to
their future because that's where their
their mind is
um they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now Lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it for 45 minutes to an hour
it's a skill now they know that they
know how to do it so now they have brain
coherence and heart coherence well once
the heart begins to become orderly and
coherent it acts as an amplifier and it
drives energy to the brain so now the
brain is getting more energy once the
heart is open and then you're thinking
different set of thoughts and those
thoughts produce different chemicals for
you to feel more of that and here comes
nitric oxide from oxytocin and then all
of a sudden your heart literally starts
to swell it literally begins to open up
and there's more energy going there and
now you're coming from a different level
of mind you have to really begin to
mentally rehearse like so you ask
yourself at the end of your day I do
this every day how'd I do how'd I do
today bro how'd you do just do good
where'd you fall from grace what what
what was it that caused you to go
unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
that I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could I involve my experience now
you may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go God the next time that
happens I think I'm going to do this or
I'm going to do that or I'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important than the news
right it's more important than answering
any email or any text it's more
important than talking about your past
or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute I just
need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't fall
from grace they don't allow their energy
to drop and so yeah in the beginning it
takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness to stay conscious
and not go unconscious but if you're
persistent and you're determined then
you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say I am not going to give my power away
to that person or that circumstance when
I can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say on a
hard day yesterday at a fight with my
co-worker or my ex or and I don't feel
like doing the work well that's the time
to get back on the horse yeah because
because it's the it's all of those times
that we self-correct those are the most
valuable moments thus people who've had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else our
research shows that when you get a
community of people together and they
begin to open their hearts and they they
have the intent for the greatest good
for people that they know or people that
they could focus on that our research
shows that you can actually affect
another person's autonomic nervous
system when you move into hard coherence
in a very non-local way well what's the
significance of that well we have an
amazing community
and our community is connected by these
elevated emotions those other emotions
of survival creates separation but we we
work to open our hearts and to feel
connected we can begin to affect people
in a very non-local way in other words
everybody else's Hearts go into
coherence at the exact same time you by
opening your heart strengthen your
connection to this community you
strengthen the connection to the people
that you relate with in your lives the
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality
to our victimization our guilt our
suffering or shame or unworthiness or
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion and stress is a lot of
energy that that we're drawing from our
very vital life force yes our resource
of light and information and we're
turning it into chemistry and we're
literally robbing the body's energy
right so so then living like that for
the short term is okay because the body
can move back to homeostasis and then
restore itself but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so again you can
eat all the right food you can do all
the right things but if you're living in
anxiety and fear and you're viewing your
world from the worst case scenario that
could possibly happen because that's
what you do in survival there's no
energy for growth and repair there's no
energy for healing so the majority of
our thoughts are signaling certain
circuits in the brain that signal
another part of the brain the limbic
brain to make what's called a
neuropeptide neuropeptides are chemical
Messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought and you're
storing it as energy in these energy
centers and and if you're living in
survival why would you open your heart I
mean it's just not a time to open your
heart I mean if you're getting chased by
T-Rex it's not a time to meditate it's
not a time to learn it's not a time to
connect it's not a time to communicate
it's not a time to sit down and go
within it's not a time to be vulnerable
it's time to run fighter hide and so is
that why we're this way I've never asked
you this before is this some I don't I
don't think you believe this but I just
want to understand is this some sort of
genetic disposition that's been passed
down to us since we've been chased by
T-Rex I think so I think survival has
been very adaptive yeah like because if
you're being chased by T-Rex you don't
run up to T-Rex T-Rex and say oh cute
little dinosaur let me pet you that's
not adaptive the fear is adaptive you
run from the unknown you learn from
challenges right so if you're living in
survival there's better chances of
surviving if you run from the unknown
and by the way when you're living in
survival add the infinite Potentials in
the quantum field you'll select the
worst case scenario in your mind and
you'll begin to emotionally prepare
yourself for the worst case scenario
because you have better chances of
surviving there you go if you prepare
for the worst right so people spend
their whole life yes thinking about the
worst thing and emotionally embracing it
while you take a thought and emotion or
an image and an emotion you're your
branding or conditioning your body into
what anxiety right into fear so then you
keep doing that over and over again over
and over again your the body becomes the
mind of fear and whether you think you
can control it or not you're gonna have
a panic attack and the panic attack is
the body saying you've conditioned me
this way try as you may with your
conscious mind and control it you
programmed it subconsciously then you
start worrying about the next panic
attack and it's that very anticipation
it keeps the person on the hamster wheel
it robs them of all of this energy as
well they're absolutely so so they don't
believe
impossibility when they're living in
that state because in survival it's not
a time to create all the blood flows
going to the hindbrain and away from the
forebrain there's no there's there's no
physiology really for a person to begin
to create a new future so then so think
about it so then 70 of the time people
in the world are living anticipating the
next moment based on their past moment
and so they're laying reality down
Moment by moment with the next known the
next predictable moment and so the
hormones of stress endorse the senses
our senses become heightened when we're
under stress and we become materialists
we narrow our focus on the danger yes so
then you're focusing on matter you're
focusing on the material world and when
you do that you put all your attention
the arousal of the stress hormones puts
all your attention on your body if
you're being chased by T-Rex you better
be paying attention to your body if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny
that your thoughts create your life
let's examine the thoughts that you
think
now you think sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts in one day
out of those sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts that you think in one day
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before
so the same thoughts will always lead to
the same choices
the same choices will always lead to the
same behaviors
the same behaviors will always create
the same experiences and the same
experiences always produce the same
emotions and those same emotions then
drive our very same thoughts and our
biology
our neural circuitry our neural
chemistry our neural hormones and even
our genetic expression stays exactly
equal to how you think how you act and
how you feel
now how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality that's it
so then if you believe just the
slightest bit in this idea that your
personality creates your personal
reality
and you wanted to change your personal
reality
that means you'd have to begin to change
your personality by thinking about what
you've been thinking about and changing
you begin to become conscious of your
unconscious habits and behaviors and
modify them
and then look at the emotions that that
keep you connected to past experiences
and decide if those emotions belong in
your future
you see most people try to create a new
personal reality
as the same personality and it doesn't
work we literally have to become someone
else
so reason this with me a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through frequent repetition a
habit is when you've done something so
many times that your body knows how to
do it as well as your mind
so if you're thinking the same thoughts
ninety percent of the time
as the day before
you're demonstrating the same behaviors
ninety percent of the time and you're
embracing the same emotions as the day
before ninety percent of the time over
time you begin to fire the same circuits
in your brain in the same sequences and
the same patterns in the same
combinations
now there's a principle in Neuroscience
that says that nerve cells that fire
together wire together
so as you think the same thoughts that
lead to the same choices that of course
produce the same behaviors that lead to
the same experiences that also
ultimately produce the same emotions
that in time you begin to hardwire your
brain into the same finite pattern
now that box in your brain there's no
literal box in your brain but that
finite signature ultimately becomes your
identity
so then most people by the time they're
35 years old
come a set of memorized behaviors
emotional reactions unconscious
attitudes beliefs and perceptions that
function like a subconscious computer
program 95 percent of Who You Are by the
time you're 35 years old is a memorized
state of being in which you've done
something so many times that your body
now is doing it better than your brain
every time you learn something new you
add a new Stitch to the
three-dimensional tapestry of your gray
matter
and if you begin to think about what you
learned you're causing your brain to
fire in new sequences and new patterns
and new combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action
so we could say then that new thoughts
should lead to new choices
and new choices should lead to new
behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences and new experiences then
should create new emotions and those new
emotions should Inspire new thoughts and
that's called Evolution a person's doing
the vision board and they're saying when
I get my new car I get my new house I
get my new relationship then I'm gonna
feel so great now that well then they're
back to the program waiting for it to
happen for them to feel the emotion
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no effect of
drawing the experience to you with that
way
so the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state for
them to feel like it's already happened
now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process and you feel grateful
you feel A Love For Life you feel a joy
for existence you feel a passion that to
for the moment
uh you will not be looking for your
future because you'll feel like it's
already happened it's the moment that we
start feeling those self-limiting
emotions that we feel separation and
then we start looking for it again well
then if you're waiting you're not
creating your you're in separation again
so then yeah so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being thoughts are the vocabulary of the
brain feelings are the vocabulary of
your body how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being so then if
you wake up in the morning and you come
come back to your senses with a clean
slate and you say I don't feel anything
and you say well let me start thinking
about all the problems in my life well
all those problems are connected to
different people or different objects of
things at different times and places the
moment you remember your problems a
memory is a record of the past you're
thinking in the past every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
them so all of a sudden you start
feeling unhappy you start feeling bitter
you start feeling frustrated so I know
your body's in the past so then most
people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to Crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine so then we want
people then to get very clear on that
vision of their future however they do
it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel from
the vision they're creating the more
altered they feel inside of them the
more they're going to pay attention to
the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment where you have that feeling
that's your compass because that feeling
is going to drive your behaviors it's
going to drive more of those thoughts
and when you feel that feeling and it's
visceral
no person no thing no experience will
stand in the way between you and that
vision and and you will be initiated in
by the universe into wealth you will be
initiated into Health you'll be
initiated into Freedom those people all
those people that have healed themselves
of all those different health conditions
they are so humble and so happy and they
feel so great that they would never
trade this feeling because of what you
thought of them they they've they've
left that program behind a long time ago
they actually don't care how you think
of them they they actually are so happy
with themselves that they're no longer
dependent on anything outside of them
now I think that's a really important
moment because that's the moment we give
people permission in our lives to do the
same right and I think that more and
more people are beginning to figure that
out one of the things about the global
pandemic that I said to my staff and to
my family the moment I heard how the
circumstances in the world changed I
just said I refuse to be a victim to
these circumstances so a victim
Consciousness is when we allow something
in our outer environment to control the
way we feel and think so if I say to you
Jay why are you so upset today and you
said oh it's because of this person or
circumstance what you're really saying
is something in my outer environment
some person or some condition is
controlling the way I think and feel and
that's not the truth that's just a
response right
so anything that controls our thoughts
and feelings causes us to be victim to
those things and the stronger the
emotion we feel to some circumstance in
our life the more we pay attention to it
and where we place our attention is
where we place our energy so we're
giving our life force we're giving our
power away to that circumstance and so I
just made up my mind that it was a great
opportunity to get into the Cocoon we've
done an experiment just 10 minutes a day
three times a day with 120 people
trading resentment frustration fear for
gratitude appreciation and thankfulness
measuring their immune response the the
chemical immunoglobulin a your primary
defense against bacteria and viruses the
best flu shot you'll ever get lives with
innately within you turns out when
you're frustrated when you're impatient
when you're fearful the immune system
dials down because you're an emergency
it's not it's that all your energy is
going for some threat in your outer
world there's no energy in your inner
world for growth and repair but how do
you turn that around so then as people
begin to open their heart
can that chemical begin to to elevate
four days
fifty percent change in the 120 people
their their IGA levels went up 50 in
four days that's your body's immune
system is now up regulating genes that
are making proteins and immunoglobulins
and antibodies that you don't need a flu
shot in other words your inner state is
greater than your outer world so then
just by doing that we now know that your
immune system is going to get stronger
by the same means take 120 people or 50
people and measure 7 500 Gene
regulations okay in four days two genes
that suppress cancer growth and tumors
are activated and upregulated the genes
that stimulate stem cells that go to
damaged tissues and repair them up
regulate them the gene for oxidative
balance is upregulated anti-cancer
anti-aging anti-hart disease anti-stroke
anti-neural degenerative
anti-inflammatory antimicrobial just
your body's naturally doing this
a gene for neurogenesis the growth of
new neurons in response to novel
experiences and learning this is four
days the gene switches on
the gene for more balance in the
pituitary and the pancreas the gene for
the microtubules of the cells the the
little the little fibers that respond to
energy and frequency so in four days we
now know that you can change your
genetic Destiny if you just practice the
inner work if you want another Amazing
Joe dispenza espresso video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there